If I think about students
now, they strike me as very poised and much more,
I don't know,
much, sappier about
the world then I was.
Now in
approaching
the world
and in considering how you
will conduct yourself,
do not be afraid of failure.
Stand up for something.
Explore and
don't expect your future to be linear when
you go from A to B to C to D
Do
not be afraid to take something of a gamble
with a piece of your life or your investment.
Particularly while your young. I would hope that
our graduates will be leaving a place like
Harvard and standing together with people
who are most disempowered and most disenfranchised
so we can begin to change those dynamics in the world.
I think that you need to stay in the moment.
It is good to meander around and that should be an exciting
thing and
not a not a bad thing.
Humor. Humor is the way to get through the adversity of life.
Watch for opportunities outside the limits of ordinary experience and discourse.
Be a better listener than a talker, then you are a great communicator.
I hope over their four years here
at Harvard that they learn
the importance
of using
the incredible education on behalf of not
only the powerful, but the powerless
And that having that power and privilege I think
requires you, gives you a moral responsibility,
to stand with those who are the least among
us.
Go home.
Make itself indispensable to that that community.
Read a daily newspaper. Get to know the problems of their
community and the people in their community.
We need an
engaged and informed citizenry
in order for society to work.
It reminds me of my favorite quotes from Margaret Mead, she said
"Never doubt that a small handful of
citizens
can change the world. Indeed,
that's the only thing that ever has."
My over all advice
is the opposite of the military. March away
from the sound of the guns.
Act as if
you love this practice. Act as if
you love the boss. Act as if
you want to  get up early and work out.
Often times being a leader, being a moral leader,
requires you to deal with, and navigate, that
kind of loneliness.
So you have to like yourself you have to know what your good at and what your not good at
It’s those periods of loneliness, of standing
on principle
of staying true to who you are, that are most
rewarding in the long term.
And I know you will succeeded in leading in any of these major fields of endeavor that you undertake.
Good Luck